people want to know if president biden's
vaccine mandates are constitutional and
the answer is probably yes the first
vaccine mandate with respect to federal
employees well the president is the
executive and he can set some rules with
respect to federal employees he can also
set a lot of rules with respect to
federal contractors now the second
mandate involves employers and employees
who are not part of the federal
government that one is on more shaky
ground but that is also probably still
constitutional why because president
biden is using osha now osha has existed
for 50 years and the whole reason that
osha exists is to create safe working
environments for employees now normally
making a rule under osha would take six
to ten years but here president biden is
using an emergency temporary standard
that can only go into effect for six
months and while courts do look at these
ets temporary standards very carefully
it's likely that he's going to prevail
here and under the jacobson case the
constitution isn't going to stop the
president from mandating a vaccine so
while we may see people in court it's
probably not going to work on these
vaccine mandates